les turcs de bulgarie
m
et
bienvenue à faculté tas nous sommes à
sofia en bulgarie dans l'un des plus
grands quartiers roms d'europe
si tu veux manger la nuit dernière sept
familles à ramasser quelques planches de
bois dans les rues de sofia
il arrache le métal pour le revendre
vous voyez il récupère ça pour acheter
du pain
non il n'y a pas d'argent ici c'est
impossible de trouver du travail quand
on est rock dès qu'ils voient qu'on les
tsiganes c'est qu'ils nous jettent comme
des malpropres
moi je dis heureusement qu'on a les
charrettes et les chevaux pour ramasser
diola si on n'avait pas ça on serait bon
pour se pendre
la bulgarie s'est peut-être l'endroit
d'europe où les roms vivent le plus mal
ce quartier s'est construit illégalement
sur les collines de sofia on y compte
plus de 35000 habitants
nous on arrive de berkowitz à là bas on
ne s'en sortait pas alors on est venus
ici on fait le tour du quartier pour
faire un peu de commerce il faut bien
vivre
moi je vends des chaussettes aller que
dieu te bénisse en bulgarie les roms
représentent entre 5 et 10% de la
population
mais pour une grande partie des bulgares
ils ne font pas partie de la société
de respect des droits des roms est une
préoccupation à ses récentes du
gouvernement pendant la période
communiste tout sentiment minoritaire
est banni les roms sont toujours
victimes de discrimination à l embauche
leur taux de chômage est cinq fois plus
élevé que pour les bulgares
le problème c'est notamment l'effet
ghetto de facultés temps tous les
enfants se retrouvent dans la même école
qui manque de matériel et d'enseignants
ce mois ci elle fête ses 60 ans
d'existence
chaque classe prépare un spectacle
en bulgarie l'école est gratuite et
obligatoire de 7 à 15 ans mais 30% des
enfants roms quittent l'école en cours
de route si les enfants ne viennent pas
c'est d'abord parce que certains parents
sont trop pauvres ils n'ont même pas de
vêtements ou de chaussures
alors ils ne veulent pas nous envoyer
leurs enfants comme ça et la deuxième
raison c'est que beaucoup de parents
sans mac ou complètement ne comprennent
pas que l'école c'est important
aujourd'hui on a encore dû aller
chercher cinq ou six enfants avec le
conseiller pédagogique
ce sont des élèves qui sont toujours
absents on n'est pas mon travail
et pendant ce temps là les enfants sont
dans la boris là bas fait partie des
bons élèves de facultés temps du haut de
ses 10 ans elle voit l'école comme une
chance
moi je voudrais être coiffeuse
si je travaille si je suis bien élevé je
pense que je vais y arriver
les parents de brice lavaur ont marié sa
soeur à l'âge de 12 ans il ne travaille
pas sa mère est souffrante depuis
plusieurs mois entrez alors comment ça
s'est passé aujourd'hui bien ça va bien
j'ai même eu un 18 aujourd'hui mon fric
tu sais je suis contente que tu résistes
bien que tu ai envie d'étudier
c'est important pour plus tard
chaque soir borislav à s'occupe de la
cuisine elle n'a pas souvent des devoirs
à faire
win tin est rôti gagnent c'est beau
c'est d'être dans la rue c'est allé de
quartier en quartier du port bouët
mais c'est vrai qu'être bulgare c'est
mieux parce que quand tu es rome si tu
n'as pas les bons diplômes
ben on jette comme un vieux chiffons que
tout va ni innovantes que tout ait à
cette pièce c'est là que d'or toutes les
familles comme les autres bulgares ils
reçoivent des allocations familiales 25
leva l'équivalent d'une douzaine d'euros
par mois et par enfant
en ce moment c'est leur seule ressource
pourquoi tous les jours mon mari
fouillent les poubelles malade ou pas
malade il part fouillait les poubelles
ils arrivent à faire 3 4 leva par jour
de quoi acheter un peu de nourriture et
disent que de rien on n'a pas grand
chose à manger au bout du compte le soir
on se couche on a besoin le matin on se
lève on a encore faim c'est pas une vie
comme la plupart des voisins cette
famille n'a pas de titre de propriété
elle peut se faire expulser du jour au
lendemain de victoire
siegen manouches gitans
quel que soit le nom qu'on leur donne ou
qu'ils se donnent les roms sont en
europe la première des minorités ils
représentent entre 10 et 12 millions de
personnes
ils sont arrivés du nord de l'inde au
moyen-âge et se sont dispersés sur tout
le continent en bulgarie ils ont été
sédentarisés de force dans les années 50
mais ils restent souvent considérés
comme des étrangers
ce que dénoncent les associations de
défense des droits de l'homme la
minorité rom est de loin celle qui
rencontre les plus grandes difficultés
ils sont 10 kg mais dont beaucoup de
sphères de la vie sociale logement
l'éducation l'emploi et depuis récemment
l'assistance sociale
c'est plus particulièrement le cas dans
les balkans où des millions ils iront
sont très nombreuses
là le cas de cette minorité est
inquiétant il ya un vrai problème social
pour entrer dans l'union européenne en
2007 la bulgarie a dû s'engager à
respecter les droits des roms
en 1999 elle a ratifié la convention du
conseil de l'europe sur la protection
des minorités
les actions en faveur des roms se sont
multipliés au point d'attirer la
jalousie de certains bulgare persuadés
qu'ils touchent d'importantes
subventions en réalité peu d'argent
arrive sur le terrain il ya un vrai
problème au niveau local de répartition
des fonds et d'action en faveur des roms
où va l'argent on sait pas trop
clairement bon on est dans des pays qui
ont des soucis de corruption énorme et
puis il ya le projet local qui fait que
les projets pour les roms pour l'instant
c'est surtout des recommandations
écrites qu'on n'applique pas ou peu sur
le terrain à faculté tas il n'est pas si
facile d'aider les roms pour monter un
dossier il faut recenser les
bénéficiaires même c'était à pose des
difficultés
résultat de nombreux programmes des dons
mis la clé sous la porte
l'association roumanie bat a tenu bon en
douze ans elle est même devenue
incontournable
huit habitants sur dix auraient déjà
toquer à sa porte pourtant l'association
ne compte qu'une dizaine de permanents
comment ces quinze dernières années on a
beaucoup travaillé sur la défense du
droit des roms aujourd'hui on sent
quelques progrès parce que la bulgarie
doit respecter le nouveau standard
européen de défense des droits de
l'homme par exemple les relations avec
la police se sont améliorées des roms ne
sont plus arrêtés sans raison après
s'être longuement battu pour les droits
des roms dans les tribunaux
l'association à recentrer son action sur
leur situation sociale son objectif
aider les roms à s'intégrer dans la
société
le plus tôt possible
loin des ruelles de raconter ta maria
vient chercher sa fille comme nati
l'association a placé trois cents
enfants roms dans cinq écoles bulgare
est bien ce qu on va regarder ça marche
des fois j'ai essayé d'inscrire ma fille
dans une école bulgare et à chaque fois
on m'a dit qu'il n'y avait pas de place
on disait toujours non alors j'ai fini
par aller voir l'association
je leur ai expliqué mon problème
ils m'ont tout de suite aidé avec eux ça
a été très vite ils m'ont trouvé cette
école qui a bien voulu de ma fille
pourquoi ici c'est mieux les enfants
étudient bien ce n'est pas le bazar
comme dans les écoles rome
là bas les enfants n'apprennent pas
grand chose
tout va mais voilà vous êtes dans une
classe mis il ya des enfants de
différentes ethnies et le point positif
c'est la socialisation la déségrégation
ont été achetés pendant 45 ans la
politique du gouvernement c'était de
séparer roms et non roms une vraie
politique de ghettoïsation on ne peut
pas effacer ça d'un coup de baguette
magique ça prend du temps pour
accompagner les enfants roms et les
aider à rattraper leur retard
l'association roumanie bat fait appel à
gallia c'est la coordinatrice
elle assure le lien avec les parents une
mission délicate mais pour que ça marche
il faut que les parents des deux
communautés se responsabilisent c'est
eux qui doivent apprendre à leurs
enfants à respecter les autres quel que
soit l'état parce qu'il y a des parents
bulgare qui ne supporte pas les roms
alors dès qu'il ya un problème à l'école
pour eux c'est forcément de la faute des
roms
l'association roumanie bat veut
impliquer la communauté comme les autres
permanents de l'association kelly a et
rome elle ne cache rien de ses
difficultés
le problème avec les roms c'est que
certains n'aiment pas travailler
ils sont d'un dollar est ce la plupart
d'entre eux on a vraiment l'impression
qu'ils attendent plus laides tombe du
ciel
à mon avis il faut vraiment qu'ils se
bougent qu'ils se prennent en main et
mettent pas du leur qui va accepter de
les aider aujourd'hui ceux qui veulent
s'en sortir quittent le quartier
souvent ils finissent par couper les
ponts avec la communauté
il n'y a pas de raison de à ce que les
gens quittent ce quartier pour s'insérer
c'est plutôt à la ville à la
collectivité locale de mettre en oeuvre
des fonds pour réinsérer cet espace là
dans la ville réussira faculté tu as
c'est difficile mais possible
il n'y a pas de lycée mais quelques
ateliers de formation bonjour c'est
notre atelier de tapisserie ici on
fabrique des chaises
l'entreprise s'appelle cas aux lianes et
ça on tienne ce sont les garçons
ici une quinzaine de jeunes sont formés
chaque année après les garçons peuvent
aussi bien travaillé dans des
entreprises bulgares que chez les roms
comme vous pouvez voir ce sont des
jeunes tout à fait normaux elle ne
ressemble pas du tout à l'idée qu'on se
fait des tigres ça fait presque un an
que je travaille ici on ne trouve pas de
travail facilement en bulgarie où ils ne
payent pas bien où travailler très dur
ici j'ai appris facilement le métier je
me sens mieux en bulgarie les minorités
représentent près de 20% de la
population estimée à 7 millions 200
mille habitants en plus des roms il ya
notamment les macédoniens les pomaks les
valaques ou encore les turcs bulgares
ils sont environ 800 milles plus
nombreux que les roms et a priori
beaucoup mieux intégrer notamment dans
la région de cars djallit une ville
moitié turc moitié bulgare comme les
roms les turcs eux sont là depuis des
siècles depuis que l' empire ottoman a
étendu ses frontières
non c'est après il ya des turcs partout
ici des commerçants turcs les policiers
ceinture même le maire et sûrs
à la différence des roms de facultés
tard les turcs vivent au milieu des
bulles gheara car djallit ils ont le
même niveau de vie les mêmes libertés
notamment celle de pratiquer leur
religion
la minorité de turquie est très bien
intégré au niveau culturel religieux et
même sociale les turcs vivent comme les
bulgares et dans chacun de ces domaines
ils contribuent au développement de la
société c'est pour ça qu'on peut dire
qu'ils sont intégrés
la particularité de la minorité turque
c'est qu'elle a son propre parti depuis
la chute du mur
le mouvement des droits et des libertés
il compte une vingtaine de députés sur
240 et pèse de tout son poids dans le
jeu politique
c'est l'un des trois partis de la
coalition au pouvoir
l'union européenne doit faire de plus en
plus face à des identités minoritaires
forte
il n'ya pas qu'en du guerrier et je
pense qu on est dans une étape de du
développement où on valorise de plus en
plus les identités qu'elles soient des
identités régionales où qu'elles soient
des identités linguistiques pour qu elle
soit d identité
et techniques etc il ya une arête
l'émergence de ces identités donc un
processus qui vient d'en bas et non pas
un processus qui est créé au quai initié
dans vos à la mairie de cars djallit
différentes minorités sont représentées
mais la plupart des employés municipaux
sont turcs
c'est le cas de messine qui revendique
une double identité
moi je suis né turc c'est pas quelque
chose que j'ai choisie c'est comme ça
certaines dates et les actes c'est pas
quelque chose que je peux renier
je peux juste être fier d'être né turc à
la bombe a fait au cap et pour effet une
baisse
je suis heureux de vivre dans un endroit
où les deux cultures se mélangent la
culture turque et la culture bulgare
mais s'il n'a pu épouser une femme
moitié turcs eux moitié bürger ce n'est
pas le cas dans toutes les familles
turques
voilà ça c'est mon fils il s'appelle
arcade c'est un nom typiquement turc
ça veut dire pur sang
le père de dessiner dentiste sa mère
infirmière ils sont à car djallit depuis
toujours et non pas le sentiment d'être
une minorité mais moi je ne fais même
pas la différence
j'ai un père bulgare et une mère turque
pour moi c'est pareil la famille c'est
la famille ça c'est pas vraiment un plat
turquie mais je les cuisine est de façon
tueur aujourd'hui les parents de décines
porte fièrement leur identité turque
la situation était bien différente il ya
vingt ans je me souviens à l'hôpital
quand il fallait promouvoir une
infirmière en chef il se débrouillait
toujours pour qu'elle soit bulgare
j'avais peut-être plus d'expérience plus
de connaissances mais il choisissait
forcément une bulgare et puis en 89
quand les événements où commencent et
c'est devenu de plus en plus dur tous
les jours je devais payer 5 levada mende
pourquoi vous deviez payer ses amendes
c'était à chaque fois que je parlais
turc
au milieu des années 1980 la pression
s'est accentuée
les turcs ont même été contraints de
prendre des noms bulgare en 1989 des
centaines de milliers de personnes sont
parties en turquie la famille de messine
est revenu en bout d'un an jour là bas
le mode de vie est très différent dit si
les gens sont plus pratiquants ils ont
des moeurs différentes
du coup le regard sur la vie n'est pas
le même ici nous sommes habituées à
vivre au milieu des chrétiens et pour
moi c'est mieux comme ça c'est plus
bariolés plus variés c'est une richesse
se mélangent
après la chute du mur
les turcs ont retrouvé leur liberté ils
ont même pu fonder un parti alors que la
constitution bulgare interdit les partis
ethniques comme une compensation pour
faire oublier ses années noires toi tout
comme rod côte d'ivoire en côte ocha
s'auto monde cet automne je le dis en
tant que représentant de la minorité
turque
je ne pense pas que ces événements
pourraient se reproduire aujourd'hui
trop je ne sens pas de telles tensions
entre les communautés
ok pour donner aux toros
dans la ville de karadj ali les
habitants sont habitués à la mixité mais
tous les bulgares n'accepte pas si
facilement ses cultures minoritaires
le parti nationaliste ataka a beaucoup
de sympathisants à sa création en 2005
il a obtenu 9 % des voix aux élections
législatives face il partage les idées
de ce parti
il est étudiant à sofia et n'aime pas
vraiment la ville de khar djallit trop
de turcs car c'est moi si je n'aimerais
les turcs
c'est à cause de l'histoire oui pendant
500 ans les turcs ont régné sur notre
pays nous ont réduit en esclavage
il ya eu tant d'atrocités des peurs les
viols des bébés tués alors - les turcs
je les accepte pas qu en observant ce
qui accentue les tensions c'est que les
minorités font plus d'enfants que les
bulgares qui ont le taux de natalité le
plus bas d'europe avec les migrations la
population diminue et d'ici quelques
dizaines d'années le poids des minorités
pourraient presque doublé il faut
abandonner l'idée que le pays est
réservé aux bulgares
malheureusement il y à des partis
politiques qui prônent ses idées à la
dernière élection un parti avait ce
slogan la bulgarie pour les bulgares
c'est quelque chose qu'on doit
abandonner tous ensemble même si au
départ la bulgarie a été fait comme un
pays pour les bégard
la bulgarie pour les bulgares dans la
région de cartes djallit il n'y a que
des turcs dans les villages en principe
le gouvernement doit leur permettre
d'étudier leur langue maternelle
oui j'essaie
à l'école de 100 ou les élèves
apprennent le turc
officiellement c'est une option mais
tous les parents l'ont choisi pour leurs
enfants
alors la plus grande partie des cours se
passent dans leur langue maternelle
racener brêteau ni l'état ni les cols
dont le droit d'imposer une langue la
culture turque fait partie de la culture
mondiale et on trouve ça normal que la
langue turque sont enseignées il y a
plein d'autres régions c'est comme ça il
y à d'autres minorités et ils apprennent
aussi leur langue maternelle
par exemple les juifs ou les arméniens
d'ici moins d'un an des élections
législatives auront lieu en bulgarie
le grand point d'interrogation c'est le
score du parti nationaliste ataka la
question des minorités est un enjeu
majeur de ce scrutin
aucune ceni
donc une